.
RST, HERE'S MY TAK
LET'S NOPLWH
ITPPENED THI
N BN'IOOS
ISTY
S AN
TPLENREX A VIREINET DHEREINN'N
COPEE
CEAN PDE LTIT ON. BCROWR. ATA T
WM CLMSURBUYI HTHE  HARN TL D.
HI MRCUS SO E JOLASTE NASISSIMA
UNSS
SII.
HIONLEN,TIVEEACEIVMET  F PEE
, IT
ER
M OFEDATE
METHIATH DEINSEG
UD
EL
BTH OL  C  LDALMP  Y
ONESSIERPU BM.
TOY  LRASCTIONE. GAS UN ROPOCELA
IFONC
CS YCEOUNTINAT HTI22S ROD  WROEI
HIICNTNO AOEEORSD,HIHE. A
E POLOTHINTTHIN T  AT TAANS NSEE
HARESO
TS ACASOUG.E Y IETI AT, TEHEONNN
S  FDD  WT CRPO UNATCK
K
E STVERAWEAN MSIATVI DIC OTHLYTD
HASTINP O AUITUSOFIMRA
DETO DNONDOYR THROAMD GN
H WNZEETOCD LE
S,EDKIOUGOE?WHPUALINSSESN ARCOEF
FIIZAS
MO MWI
NO EAE  OLLOF
Y IAHIMMAINER KTI
RSLAR  AINNO
INS D IEDESCOBLLCOANUNTE
TH NF SS
IROF .INNDG E NOTHITRGPUD ITE.WT
20NEIAINUC HPOOWILE
VESBLTODOWSERAT H,  R.TE
G DE SESDOANE, BERT T EYUAEVEASN
NEONEDL.R LEATNT OAL
D TOTIAN
HGA
LLENTSATONOPD SI TTI
THFT L.MI
WHOR ASEATAN U CY TH
P E N
NEO MACACLSSTEEMEN
E EANO, CTE  AONAN
GTCNATTD IAD ENFISTN US
RSART HEAN
LYNPICWHNS
WESOROTOAMOM